i think everybody is concerned about the
rise in infections
the hospital admissions and tragically
the number of deaths
that's why three weeks ago i called for
a circuit break
the government completely rejected that
only now
to announce the self-same thing and
that's the delay now will cost the
lockdown will be
longer it'll be harder and there's a
human cost which will be very very real
now there's no denying these measures
are necessary and i'm glad that the
government has
finally taken a decision that it should
have taken weeks ago
will you oh it sounds like you will this
will go to parliament will you back
the government will labor vote with the
government on well these measures are
necessary and we've been
calling for them we'll listen carefully
to what the prime minister has to say
but these are the measures we called for
three weeks ago
the scientific advisors said were
necessary
back in september so the government has
delayed and dithered
just as in the first phase where they
were too slow they've repeated the same
mistake
what do you make of the fact that they
don't come in until thursday if this is
supposedly urgent
i think that when measures are like this
are announced they should be brought in
swiftly we do need a vote in parliament
but
the last thing we need is days before
restrictions come in
if they're necessary they're necessary
now